good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I am very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our
2022-2023 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar Series this lecture
series is supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series has focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
differing themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences this year's theme is
data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where each Friday we enjoy presentations
from leading thinkers about the issues
promise opportunities hurdles and other
things associated with understanding the
secondary health effects of covet 19.
these include delayed Health checkups
treatments mental health drug abuse
increased obesity obesity and the long
lingering health effects associated with
the star's covid-19 virus participants
selected for our biomedical data science
Innovation lab program will leverage
these presentations as vital material
for our culminating in-person Grant
project development Workshop to be held
at the lodge at Saint Edwards Park in
Seattle Washington in June of 2023.
today I am delighted to welcome our
speaker Dr velashade Augusto from the
Department of ecology and evolutionary
biology at the University of Kansas Dr
Gusco has trained as an applied
mathematician who designs novel epidemic
models to gain insights into the
emergence and re-emergence of infectious
diseases of Public Health importance and
how to mitigate the risk that they pose
to human health she holds PhD in
mathematics from the University of
Lauren in Nigeria as well as a master's
degree in mathematics also from the
University of Illinois in Nigeria she
has designed and analyzed novel models
of diseases like Ebola Avian Influenza
bowline tuberculosis Jones disease
amongst others her current works is on
modeling of tick-borne disease across
the Great Plains and understanding the
role of human behavior on the
transmission of covet 19. her Outreach
programs involve capacity building and
knowledge transfer across West Africa by
organizing summer schools in
mathematical epidemiology ecology
throughout the African continent
in continuing our
2022-2023 biomedical data science
seminar series theme her lecture today
is entitled understanding the impact of
the covid-19 pandemic on Mental Health
using network analysis Dr Gusco will
discuss the impact of covid-19 policy
actions on Mental Health in the country
using mental health related indicators
such as feeling anxious feeling
depressed and worrying about finances
using survey data that her group has
analyzed from the Delphi Group at
Carnegie Mellon University
as always we are streaming this live uh
this lecture live and for recording via
YouTube and if you are watching on
YouTube we thank you very much for
joining us also our specially selected
2022 2023 biomedical data science
Innovation lab participants and alumni
are encouraged to submit any questions
they have via the chat feature in their
Zoom sessions I will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and with that welcome flowers
today we are very excited to hear your
presentation well thank you
um thank you for the invite I greatly
appreciate it
um so as we all know could be 19 is a
respiratory disease caused by the novel
coronavirus sasko V2 and since it's
Discovery in Wuhan China in 2019
covid-19 has led to over
670 million cases globally and over 6.8
million deaths and as you can see from
this
um geographical map this is indeed a
pandemic because every city is in every
towns in every countries have been
impacted and is being impacted by these
disease
now in a bit to control the disease the
spread of the virus initially different
needs to get mitigation efforts were put
in place so efforts such as social
distancing school and events closing
travel bans infected individuals where
quarantine or unsuspected cases where
advices self-isolate and so some of
these measures may have far-reaching
impacts on people's mental health and
um and that of the general population
so our objective in this study are
three-fold one to understand the impacts
of covid-19 on people's mental health
across the country to identify the
similarities between the states in terms
of individuals mental health and to
understand the impacts of governments
and state specific policies on people's
Mental Health
so as overview to this presentation I
will start with a little bit of
um I'll talk a little bit about the data
and the government policy guidelines in
place during the time frame of our study
and since we are using network analysis
I will talk a little bit about the or
look at the relationship between mental
health and government guidelines and
briefly go over the methods that we used
um which is the clustering and the
Coalition method and the dynamic
connectome and lastly I will conclude by
presenting some results and then I will
close with a summary
so I'll start with the mental health and
related data and policy guidelines
so the data we use are publicly
available and there are aggregated
surveyed results data from Carnegie
mellons University Delphi Group now this
group distributed covid-19 Trends and
impact survey in partnership with
Facebook in the form of a daily
voluntary survey that Facebook users
where could respond to
survey questions
ranged from those concerning physical
health to economic impacts of clothing
19 and to mental and behavioral problems
so for this study
we selected three indicators of interest
to represent the impact of covid-19 on
people's mental health so these are the
percentage of participants who
experience feelings of an um of anxiety
within the last seven days the
percentage of participants who were
depressed within the last seven days and
the percentage of participants who were
worried about their Finance for for the
following month
so in addition to looking at the
individual states we group the data in
two different ways geographically and
politically
so this is the geographical map of the
country divided into four regions namely
the Midwest the Northeast the South and
the West
and there are different ways in which
the country can be splits geographically
so in many cases it may be based on
historical relationship within certain
regions this relationship can stem from
similar religious community cultural
similarities shared historical
significance or similar climates in the
region so in this study we used a
geographical grouping from the United
States Census Bureau
now
this is the
this is the map of the country along
political party preference and we
focused on the two major political
parties the Democrats and the
Republicans and the the political party
preference was determined from the
results of the 2020 presidential
election
so these are the data
um along Regional lines for the
percentage of individuals feeling
anxious feeling depressed and worried
about finance and these are the same
data that we have grouped along
political party preferences
so in order to see if there is any
relationship between
um the trends in mental health
indicators and the trends in the
covid-19 cases
hospitalization and that we also grouped
the coveted related data long Regional
lines and political lines so these are
showing the regional lines grouping and
these are the ones for the political
lines grouping
and we see from this plot three
distinguishable waves so the first wave
was from March 2nd to July 1st 2021 and
the second wave was from July 2nd to
November 11 2021 and the Third Way was
from November 12
2021 to January 10th 2022 which was the
end of uh a study period
so several policy several mandates were
enacted to alleviate the public Public's
burden of the pandemics some policies
was about Nationwide vaccine rollouts
for all adults unemployment benefits and
eviction moratorium and we postulate
that some of these policies could impact
individuals Mental Health so here are
the least of the mental health policies
and mandates now these sets of policy
guidelines might affect feeling anxious
and and depressed because it involves
controlling the disease
now these sets of guidelines might
affect finances because it involves
unemployment benefits stimulus check and
eviction moratorium
so
that's that with the policy guidelines
so now I will talk a little bit about
the methods we use starting with the
correlation and clustering
so to create the network across the
states we started by obtaining a
correlation coefficient Matrix for each
pair of the states using the time the
time series data for each of the mental
health related data
and we use the testing
the passing correlation formula to
determine the correlation between states
X and Y
now if the Coalition coefficients is not
equals to zero that in the case that
states X and Y are connected otherwise
they're not connected if the coefficient
is bigger than zero it indicates that
this the two states X and Y uh I have
positive correlation between them and if
the Coalition coefficients is
smaller than zero it indicates a
negative correlation between
um between the two states
um before I move on
and we use this correlation coefficient
Matrix to form the adjacency Matrix
which defines the connectivity of States
on a network with respect to a
particular indicator and we use all the
correlation coefficients unlike what is
normally done where a cutoff is set and
Only the Strong Association are
considered
um so we wanted to incorporate all the
broad ranges of the states similarities
and not just the positive ones
so once we've obtained our connectivity
Matrix Network next we cluster the
states according to how similar they are
using the leading algorithm
we first split the network into positive
and negative sub network based on the
sign on the correlation Matrix the
positive sub Network contain only the
positive connections from the original
Matrix and the negative subnets will
contain only the negative connections
from the original Network
we then apply the fine petition function
to both sub Network to obtain the
cluster for each of the sub networks and
then we apply the optimize partition
Multiplex function
to both sets of cluster to obtain a
single set of cluster for the original
Network now since the cluster is
returned by Leading algorithm are not
unique we run the leading algorithm
multiple times in order to create a
consensus cluster
and then lastly we construct an
allegiance Matrix with all the mental
health indicators in this case we only
have three so we use all three to create
the allegiance Matrix now the allegiance
Matrix gives us the probability of two
regions being in the same Community
across all the mental health indicators
so next I will display the results of
the consensus and Allegiance clustering
which we use to group similar States
together
so here are the clustering of the
indicators for feeling anxious and
worried about Finance the colors
indicate the clustering of the states
now with this indicator with these two
indicators we see two clusters and you
can see that the Southern States
are mostly in one cluster
fulfilling depressed indicates uh we see
three clusters with no distinctive
pattern on like what we have for feeling
anxious and worried about Finance where
the southern states are clustered are
mostly clustered together
Now using all the three mental health
indicators we create an allegiance
clustering of the states
these Syndicate this indicates which
states are mostly likely to be grouped
together or exhibit similar Trends
across all three mental health
indicators and here we see three main
clusters based on the colors the
southern states are mostly grouped
together except for Arkansas Virginia
and West Virginia which are not so
frequently grouped together with the
rest of the Southern States
now this coloring light blue
include California Illinois Nevada
and North Dakota which are non Southern
States and we should note that the
southern states are also Republican
states except for Georgia and Virginia
I'm going by the 2020
um presidential election
so now move on to the dynamic connectome
and how we created the associated Time
series
so we use the sliding window to create
the dynamic connection of each indicator
time series now this technique is
commonly used in the field of
Neuroscience to examine brain natural
Dynamics
so in our sliding window analysis we
took a fixed window of 30 days and we
Slide by one one day and we then
computed the average correlation
values for mental health indicators and
across the mental health we um across
the network we've been within the
particular window that we're sliding
through
now these
the slides or snapshot leads to a Time
series which we plot to display the
dynamic fluctuation in in the indicator
of Interest across the time frame that
we used so we did this for the three
um mental health indicators that that
um that we were considering
so now I will show you the results of
the dynamic connector constructed using
the sliding window analysis
so here the plus of the dynamic
connectome along geographical regions
and political party preference for each
of the mental health indicators and as
um
as mentioned earlier on WE observed
three waves in the time frame that we
use service please so that splits the
dynamic connection for each of the
indicators or into three and and we
indicate each wave with a vertical
dashed line with this blue vertical
dashed lines and the um the horizontal
dashed line is just to show the width of
the wave
so if we look at all the plots together
this is what we have
um so when I say all the plus together I
mean all the plus together for the
regional connect tone as well as the
political connectum so this is what we
have and we see for the first wave
um
the Midwest the Northeast and the
Democrats or the Democratic states have
the highest average correlation for
feeling anxious and feeling depressed so
we're looking at this first part of
um
for this particular indicator and this
indicator
so the
Midwest Northeast under Democratic
states have the highest average
correlation value during that time frame
however for worried about Finance
there's a weak correlation between each
region or political
party States except during the initial
parts of the first wave so I'm looking
at this here where the Southern and the
Republican states have the highest
average correlation
for the second wave we see the southern
states so that's this middle part here
for the three indicates of whether
you're looking at the geographically or
politically
so the southern states and the
Republican states consistently have the
highest average Coalition value for
feeling anxious and feeling depressed
um as well as worried about Finance
but the Third Way
um we didn't see any distinctive pattern
for for all the indicators and the
overall in the correlation value is weak
and and negative in some instances
um which just simply show that
during this period in the pandemic there
is no strong similarities between the
states
since we're dealing with network here at
the dynamic connectome for the
eigenvector centrality across Regional
and political party preferences the
eigenvector centrality measures the
transitive influence of each state so it
tells us which how important it the
connection of each states are
we also have all all of them put
together the eigenvectors centrality the
time series of the eigenvector
centrality along with General minds and
political ones
so we also see similar Trends with the
Midwest Northeast and the Democrat
Democratic states having the largest
eigenvectors centrality during the first
wave while the Southern and the
Republican states have the largest
sagging Vector centrality during the
second wave
um there are no distinctive pattern in
this that during the third wave
um but the values
um are much larger than the average
correlation values that we observed with
the Coalition connectum that I showed
down now
so
um as I've shown me all this
analysis that we've done the results
that we've obtained so the question
you'll be asking is so how do we bring
all this together how do we assess the
impact of these policies and mandates on
people's Mental Health
so to assess the impact of this policy
on people's mental health we superimpose
the correlation
outcomes onto the kovi 19 related data
and identified the policy implemented
during this this times
so this allows us to see if a
correlation value was indicative of the
covid-19 cases hospitalization
um debts and the implemented policy
so I will discuss the results using the
political party Dynamic connectum since
I have fewer curves on that plots unlike
the regional ones the conclusion of the
results of the geographical regions
um
are some are the same and I'll show this
later on
so I will start with feeling anxious and
feeling depressed
so for either of this mental health
indicator we see that the Democratic
states have the highest correlation
value during the first wave now during
this particular period there were two
policies implemented so the first policy
was on April 19th which guarantees that
all American
adults are eligible for kovi 19 vaccine
and we assume we reasonably assume that
this led to a decrease in recorded
percentage of anxiety and the and
depression
the second policy was the CDC guideline
or guideline updates on masking which is
made on May 13th in their guidelines CDC
retracted their recommendations for
fully vaccinated individuals to wear
masks indoors or Outdoors now this
policy however
is kind of ambiguous in the way
individuals we interpret this because
some individuals can consider this
guideline to indicate a decrease in
severity and danger of covid-19 pandemic
While others may see these as a
premature decision and worry about the
potential outcome of making
these announcements
so notice that during this period
the Democratic states experienced the
most kovid
kovi 19 cases hospitalization and debt
so we're talking about this time frame
um in the
um in the pandemic during the pandemic
and so overall it makes sense that the
Democratic states have the highest
correlation values
um
um as regarding to feeling anxious and
depressed
um
even though feeling
um even to feeling depressed and feeling
anxious were on the on on the decline
during the spirit so right now I'm
showing you the the plot for feeling
depression so you can see during this
first wave that individuals the level of
the percentage of individuals swimming
depressed was on the decline and if I
slide
um
move the slide
backward by just just the slide you can
also see that for feeling anxious that
that is also the case
so doing the second wave we see an
increase in the correlation values
within the Republican states
now during this time CDC announced on
July 3rd that covid-19 Delta variance
was responsible for over 50 percent of
all covid-19 cases
and we noticed that
that was this there's this large
increase in copied cases hospitalization
and debts among Republican states
and it makes sense to see that the
percentage of those feeling anxious and
depressed was high in the Republican
states during the second second frame
time frame
and during the Third Way the Coalition
between the states
were weak and during this period FDA
extends the fisa eligibility to 16 and
17 year olds and CDC shortened the
isolation and quarantine period
so during this third wave
um the curvy 19 cases hospitalization
um and hospitalization was on the rise
mostly in the Democratic states while
the debts were higher
um in the Republican states which
explains the high anxiety and depression
in the Republican states
so for worried about Finance indicator
we see this High initial correlation
value among both political party States
um during the first wave so that's this
initial part here
and which aligns with
um the percentage of people worried
about Finance in the first few days of
this time frame
however we start to see this decrease in
the number of individuals worried about
finance and during this period in time
on Match 11 President Biden signed a
coronavirus relief package which
extended on employment's compensation
and included a third wave stimulus check
now during the second wave we see an
increase in the percentage so we start
to see this increase in the percentage
of individuals worried about their
finances within both States but mostly
among the Republican states
so however during this time we see a
large
um a large increase in covid cases for
v19 cases hospitalization and debts in
the Republican parties this of course
was when CDC announced the presence of
the Delta variants now during the third
wave there was no clear correlation
between the political States but overall
individuals in the Republican states
worried more about their finances than
individuals in the Democratic states
so here at the regional connectum for
feeling anxious and feeling depressed
and worried about finance and the same
factors
influencing the dynamic connection for
political parties also affects the
regional connectum
so this is filling billing anxious
feeling depressed and worried about
Finance
so this is a short talk and so to
conclude
in this work we use clustering in
network analysis
to study the similarities between States
and how covid-19 impacts the mental
health across the country
across the country
um
using mental health indicators such as
worried about Finance feeling anxious
and human depressed we superimpose our
Coalition outcomes
onto covid-19 related data so mainly the
coveted cases hospitalization and debts
as well as on to the implemented
policies and mandates that were enacted
to alleviate the pressure of covid-19 on
individuals in the community and our
results
with numerous studies our results agrees
with numerous studies that observed an
increase in negative mental health
conditions across across the country in
parallel Will Be Imagined so it could be
19.
and we saw that the southern states
clustered together in the same group
fulfilling anxious and worried about
Finance indicators
um we didn't see any
identifiable communities clustering for
feeling depressed
using connectome results are connecting
results we saw an increase in feeling
anxious and feeling depressed in the
southern states which overlapped with
increase in covid-19 related cases
that's hospital and hospitalization when
the death of variance was spreading
rapidly
um we saw an increase in worries about
Finance which can be explained by the
emergence of the Delta variance and we
also saw that the economic the
government economic belief package only
impacted this mental health indicator
during the first wave of of our time
frame of a study time frame
so before I conclude this work was was
led by Kobayashi who was then an
undergrad student and currently
interviewing for grad school
in cell biology neuroscience and
physiology
um so she was supported by Raul's sons
who um was also another former undergrad
in my lab in my um in Alexander Falk
who's my current grad students so this
work was supported by grants from NSF
so thank you I will take your questions
wonderful thank you so much a pleasure
it looks as if that period of around
October of 2021 looked like a
particularly Salient period from some of
the graphs that you showed and uh in
particular there seemed to be
um more deaths amongst those who
identify as Republican and I'm curious
if you had any evidence to indicate that
some of that might have been due to
resistance to vaccinations or to social
distancing policies or other things that
might have been fueled by the media
during that time and I don't know if you
have data to support that or if you have
any suspicions about that
um but maybe you could comment
well that's that's a really great
comment
um we did not think about that when we
were looking at this results
um that that would be something for us
to to investigate a little bit more but
we did not look at we didn't consider
that when we were looking at this yeah
it just looks like that that period of
time all of a sudden
the graphs sort of diverge and even if
there are periods where
you know earlier in an earlier way of
their you know the blue line was higher
it was like
a delay of the inevitable in some
instances where there might have been
some resistance to it but eventually
there was no hiding from it and I'm just
kind of wondering if that was evident
from any media I'm not sure what data
exists there but if that that might be
helpful to try to explore yeah we will
definitely look at this um because right
now this this work is on under review so
we've just gotten the first review
comments back and with this comments we
would certainly look at that to see if
that is I'm having any influence on what
we're seeing with the debts
um among the Republican states and I'm
I'm not so sure among the stubborn
States as well because it is kind of
interesting to see some of those
differences uh in the Curves in terms of
you know here the one you're showing on
the screen now so in terms of you know
feeling anxious you know right around
that time you know the seeing a change
in the number of of cases and
hospitalizations and deaths you know
during that particular
window of the fall of 2021 uh yeah it
was it wasn't good
of one particular uh political party
than the other that would just be
interesting to see if that correlated
with any of the news media
right so this way so we were going we're
doing a lot of back and forth and trying
to superimpose things
um but we did that for some reason we
didn't think about that
um because in other work that we've done
we've looked at
um
um public sentiments not not in this
work so we've looked at public
sentiments actually used in Twitter data
to look at that and so that's what I was
going to suggest or ask about is that if
you didn't have an opportunity to look
at some kind of archival Twitter related
activities around those times and see if
that didn't uh maybe anticipate like the
number of cases and hospitalizations and
deaths that occurred
um you know if Twitter was particularly
active uh you know in the weeks prior
it's kind of anticipated it but anyway
I'll leave it to you to go look that up
my another question I have is are you um
looking to extend these analyzes and
carry the timelines forward in as we're
kind of you know entering or you know in
the midst of I guess this post-covet era
um to see how any of these sentiments
have changed even though cases
hospitalizations and deaths have uh kind
of mitigated
well that that's
suggestion which
it will be an interesting thing to look
at but my concern is the data that we
would use to be able to do that
um
because I am not sure whether the Delphi
Group continues to track this
um this sort of data because since we
use their data to do that
um and I'm not
we would have to look at if we need to
like use Twitter data to be able to see
um
see what what people's sentiments are
you can be able to track that data okay
so with the Delphi people have they um
I'm not familiar with them but that
doesn't mean anything but I'm curious
did they uh have they stopped collecting
any further data as of January of 2022
or I I
I
I don't want to I don't want to be
definitively and say no yes I'm not sure
but I I think that they have so but I'm
not sure and what role do you think that
um data scientists and people with
quantitative backgrounds mathematicians
and
um other folks who are interested in the
modeling of these things what what
further do they have to add to help
guide future mental health related
research and policies
um that's a that's a deep one
um
well I I believe that the role would
just be for us to continue to
um shine lights and what we're currently
doing and showing the um
the necessity for this collaborative
work that
um this is bringing together
um I mean bringing people with different
and diverse background together
um
because on our own as as mathematicians
um we would need
um biologists even though I'm I'm a
mathematician house in the biology
departments we would still need people
with
uh you know people in social sciences to
help with the interpretation of the
results that that we've gotten like you
can clearly see from even the questions
that you're asking me about
um
considering
um the resistance that people had which
we didn't think about
um I I did this work with my undergrad
so we didn't think about that so but
it's we've done this work with
um you know more individuals with with
social scientists as we have with our
ongoing projects looking at
incorporating human behavior we would be
able to have
um better interpretation and explore
better
better Avenue and questions concerning
this
concerning you know the the problem that
we're currently facing and so I I think
that having collaboration with
um
individuals from different fields would
help shine lights and to
um mental health situations that that
were faced particularly with the the
outcome of with this pandemic what we're
currently faced with this pandemic
so I'm sensing that you have an
appreciation for a team science kind of
an approach and I'm curious if you know
you were able to leverage you know
people from other disciplines
um in the analyzes of these data and get
their assistance in their interpretation
um or whether you have done so in other
projects that you've undertaken
um I have done so in other projects that
I have done undertaking but not for not
with this particular project so with
this particular project it was done with
um my undergrad students
but with other projects like the public
sentiments one so we had
um we had an economist in the group who
who's an expert in
um
um working with Twitter data and other
kinds of data of that nature so he did
the sentiment analysis that we used
um and we also on another different
projects we um we had um a game theorist
in the group world who helped with
um formulating some of the the the model
aspect of what I wanted so I'm like this
is what I want
um and and then I and then he helped to
craft the model the way that I wanted it
um so I have done some collaborative
work with or there's now not on this
particular budget and I continue to do
that even with other things that I'm
working on like the tick projects that I
um that you mentioned earlier on
um across great the Great Plains so
um we have a team of
um biologists and people who would do
experiment testings and I would just
come in with my modeling background my
math modeling background to model things
and and then we'll bounce ideas off each
other
tell us a little bit more about your
tick-borne illnesses that you're doing
throughout the Great Plains I'm I'm sure
that there's a data science a major data
science element to that the modeling
aspect but also the team science kind of
approach that you're you're drawing from
can you tell us a little bit more about
that project uh certainly
um so this is an epscore project
um
that involves
um I think six universities across
Kansas and Oklahoma and so we've been
collecting a team has been collecting
take data um at different sites
um since I think
um just before the Kobe I think
um and so they've collect they've been
collecting this data
um and
right now we have
um
so we have so the goal is to be able to
look at the phenology well not that's
not just the goal So based on the data
we've collected we've seen some
interesting results based on
um the phenology of the textout that
were collected
um across across the two states and we
have a team of scientists who will be
testing those takes for Packaging
and one of the interesting things that
we've seen is that
um I think it's the Exodus species of
Optics some of them are winter ticks and
which is something that we didn't see or
others haven't seen before
um so these sticks come out in the
winter
as against what we expect which you know
they expect them to come out in in the
spring I think but then instead they
come out in the winter
um so our team have been collecting this
data and
um right now I'm doing some modeling
work where we are also because I'm
interested in looking at mitigation
efforts when it comes to different
diseases
um so we have a couple of papers where
um by prescribed fire is a mitigation
efforts
um used in controlling the takes
um
so we've seen from from the study well
from the modeling effort that prescribed
fire has some impact in reducing and
reducing tics but which of course
um does not
um totally eliminates the text and so
um this summer I will be leading a
research group in
um the um African in diaspora research
group in Berkeley
mmsri
Berkeley research group
um looking at tics and um and takes
control and fire
um where the goal is
to well the question I'm interested in
addressing is
given the fact that fire cannot
prescribe fire cannot completely
eliminate ticks
um what other mitigation efforts will be
necessary to be able to control the
ticks
that sounds like a fascinating project
uh with many dimensions and a lot of
painstaking work
um so we wish you all the all the uh
good luck in in as you undertake that
project it sounds fascinating I know one
other thing that you do which I'm
curious to hear about is um some of the
work that you're you're doing
um with the summer school that you run
in Ghana and I know that you're you're
probably also connected to folks in
Nigeria as well tell us a little bit
more about
um some of your activities in Africa
um so
I am running
um
um a mobile clinic like thing so I call
it mobile cleaning because we're going
from one country to another in West
Africa specifically in West Africa for
this particular summer school
um so we've been so we started with
um we started in Benin and then we went
to Senegal and then Nigeria and this
summer
we're going to to Ghana and so we've
gotten some seed money from simplest of
that Center for
um
pure and applied math I think
um so they've given us some seed money
which we're still looking for more money
so
um if you know how I can get my money I
would really appreciate it because it
supports the um it supports Master's
students to come to this Workshop where
we
um you know have some
some two weeks training we give them
some classes and then some projects to
work on during the two weeks and so
we've gone through we've gone to those
countries and my whole piece that once
we leave
um
Ghana we can go to another West African
country I am particular about West
African country because
um there is a big
um
um group in southern Africa I'm also
part of that group
um well it's an offshoot song but I'm
not sure whether it's an offshoot but
but I but they're they're together you
have um samsa and then you have masamu
samuis mathematics in Swahili I think
um so I'm part of the masama group where
we are
collaborating with um
with African scientists to do different
projects and so the goal is to also do
this capacity building and Technology
transfer I am at
um I am a product of such collaborative
efforts and so this is with dymax way
back when I was a grad student so
Dynamics and some some folks who do this
training Workshop
where I met my postdoc Mentor since I'm
Reinhardt and I was able to come to the
states and work with her and I'm here
now so I I see this as an opportunity to
give back to my community and and help
with the knowledge Gap that I know that
would um we're experiencing as well I
think that's that's really great
um and I completely agree that having
that opportunity to give back to the
community is super super important and
I'm curious if you are from familiar
with the H3 Africa people
um that I believe are in Cape Town are
you familiar with that ever
um
maybe if I know the full meaning of H3
and while H well the H uh is uh human
heredity in hell out of Health in Africa
so that's what the h's stand for
um but it's based at the um in Cape Town
and they are actually NIH funded
um which is kind of interesting and they
are really trying to integrate Global
Health
um data science there's a huge data
science component to it public health
looking at uh heritable diseases but I
think they also are looking at
um things like you know various viruses
and communicable disorders and whatnot
who may be more susceptible
um but I would encourage you if you're
looking for connections who may be able
to help you identify means of further
support connect with the H3 Africa folks
um it's
h3africa.org and um they are I I know
you're focused in West Africa but I
think they're really looking across
those countries from across the African
continent
to our you know for political reasons
able to come together there are some
countries in in Africa where that's not
possible
um but in in those that are they are
just having a um a uh they're rather
they just had the 20th H3 Africa
Consortium meeting in Cape Town
um where they had a quite a big
Conference of folks from around Africa a
couple of years ago I had an opportunity
to go to Cape Town and participate in
one of their H3 Africa activities
concerning um bioinformatics and uh it
was it was a fantastic time and I
thoroughly enjoyed my visit and um they
are very interested in identifying
collaborators and so that may be a good
option for you
um and they may also have access to some
data types that perhaps maybe
very uh interesting for you to consider
modeling
right I will I would reach out to them
I'll look at the website then we chats
around definitely do that
um and uh I'm uh Curious at how long
have you been at the University of
Kansas
um so I've been at the University of
Kansas since 2016.
um after my post-op at the National
Institute for
mathematical and biological synthesis
nimbios um I got a job at Austin Peay
State University in Tennessee
um I was there from 2011 to 20 2015
um before and and then I I first came to
to the University of Kansas
um as the Langston Hughes fellow as
their first stem fellow so they have
this program where they bring
um
minority
scholar to the university up and coming
minority scholar to the university
um but so I happen to be there for stem
fellow the program had been on since the
70s I think the late 70s but for well I
don't know or whatever reason they never
had any stem person until me well you
did them a favor it sounds like for you
yeah so and then I was I came I spent a
semester
um where I walked on a malaria model
multi-skem malaria model so I created
the first multi-school malaria model
used in the life stages of the parasite
Inhumans and in mosquito
um with my colleague
Maria Riva and Maria light from
University of Florida
Saint Petersburg
um so after that they they offered me
the job and I started in 2016 and I got
tenured just this last year so which is
very exciting congratulations thank you
so what do you as we kind of look to
wrapping up here what do you see
happening
um
with this type of modeling over the say
next five to ten years
um
what I see have
he has already started happening
um in the sense that
um we will see more realistic models
coming up and NSF head NF NSF is in the
Forefront of that pushing that with the
call that they had where well the
quality is ongoing and they had a call
last year on how to create models
incorporates in human behavior because
with most of the covid models that
um people focused on last year
um the human components wasn't included
and so NSF put a call out for people to
submit proposal to create models
incorporating human behavior and our
team just happens to be one of those
first
um
18 supported by NSF to incorporate human
behavior and our team will be looking at
the consequences of isolation and
incorporating human behavior into those
model consequences of isolation on
um
on domestic violence opiate misuse
yeah so so that that is what I see
happening in the next 10 years there
will be a more realistic models
um where we will be accounting for this
human behavior and consequences of of um
of outbreaks such as covid-19
um public sentiments and people
sentiments and all these sort of
um human behavior will be incorporated
into into the models and not just the
traditional
compartmental model that we've been
doing
um in the past
well
Alaska day Augusto from the Department
of ecology and evolutionary biology at
the University of Kansas thank you so
much for sharing this work with us
giving us a lot of food for thought I
encourage you to reach out to the H3
Africa people I think you may find some
uh interesting
comrades there
um and do keep going with this uh really
impressive work and uh we look forward
to kind of watching further progress
here over the next decade or so thank
you again
thank you I appreciate the invite thank
you everyone for joining us today next
week we're uh taking a little spring
break so we will not be having a um uh
seminar series lecture next week but
we'll see you the following week um as
we continue our lecture series into the
spring so uh have a wonderful weekend
everybody have a good spring break and
we'll see you again real soon thank you